i loved seeing you speak out on the free
brittany movement the things that's
going on with her
knowing what you know having worked with
britney do you feel like you speaking
out in defense of her is something that
would not fly in the past especially
like by her dad um i doubt it flies now
right it's not about her dad it's about
brittany you know so
like my i don't feel an allegiance to
britney spears's father
yeah you feeling allegiance to brittany
though yeah yeah of course because i
grew up watching her and i idolized her
and i still do
and she's really kind lovely person
[Music]
and beyond the fact that we collaborated
together she
put her faith in me to produce that
music video for her and
develop the cover art and all these
other things and she's the only artist
that ever really gave me that
opportunity
i get a lot of compliments from artists
saying oh i love your stuff so much but
none of them ever kind of try to hire me
and let me like have free reign on that
kind of thing and
she did and she's a superstar so amazing
i
love her so much and i just want what
everybody wants of her just for her to
be happy so
hearing her speak out and share her
unhappiness
i just felt that me having firsthand
uh perspective about what's going on and
stuff i
wanted to just say my piece that i
i support her and i think she's you know
she deserves that
you got the new record coming out august
13th and
i got to tell you the track list at
least on paper
it looks like you got some wild stories
to tell so
i mean what's the vibe of the album it
kind of takes you down
a bit of a trip sonically down memory
lane of all the things that i've touched
on
and then narrative wise i'm
always talking my but
then i'm also just kind of drawing from
past stories of crazy
that i used to do when i was in my early
20s especially spending a lot of time in
miami and
kind of being that like club kid going
out with your friends or maybe dealing
with relationships that aren't going
good
um you know those sorts of things but
from the perspective of how i
viewed it or felt about it um when i was
younger and then working its way
up until the now and it's just like a
little time capsule for me of
really my twenties and it was so much
fun making it
[Music]
dance
with some of the criticism over i am the
strip club you know a lot of
some people were accusing you of black
fishing which you spoke out
right yeah why why did you feel like it
was important to say something again
you know to address these trolls i think
that that is a real thing that some
women
do do it's a real problem but uh this is
the same foundation that i was wearing
in the music video i wear the same
foundation every time and i tell them
i don't you know i don't think that's
the case it was
i just we needed to make the lighting
really dim and red for a club scene and
i
i think it was more so the shock factor
of seeing me in a black wig
that people were not used to seeing me
like that or seeing me have the heavy
duck eye makeup i think it really uh
threw people up but people do love to
sometimes i think they do it on purpose
to me uh because they love
troll me or i am a bit of a gemini and i
love to snap back and i do love to have
reactions
sometimes i think maybe i'm someone
people enjoy doing that too more because
they get
they do get a reaction a little more
than with other people so
but and i i
i kind of dusted off and i honestly
don't really you know
care but um in that respect i just i do
take that kind of an accusation a little
more seriously and i'm like
you